I have got four belly blasting supplements
you can add to your diet-
-many benefits of magnesium and how to get
more magnesium rich food-
-If you've been following my newsletter, you've
heard me talk about probiotic-
Supplements like vitamins, herbs and protein
powders comprise 36 billion dollars
in annual US retail sales.
And it's almost completely unregulated.
We have developed the ultimate male vitality
supplement with eight concentrated super herbs.
An open marketplace has facilitated experimentation,
but it's also allowed products to flourish
like Herbalife,
which some claim is a pyramid scheme that
doesn't help users lose weight.
Allegations that the company denies.
Now under investigation by the FBI and the
Federal Trade Commission.
Neal Thanedar set out to bring accountability
to the market without quashing it's dynamism.
You don't know what you're taking.
There could be a fish oil capsule that's 10%
omega 3s, there could be one that's 90% omega 3s.
There could be what we found
which is thatabout a third of the capsules that are actually on the shelf are rancid.
I think what Labdoor does provides kind of
this nice balance between
some sort of regulatory function
but at the same time, it's a free market,
right?
We're, you can, like anyone can sell a product,
if you do something wrong we'll catch you,
or like we'll do our best to catch you.
But we're not blocking the products from the
market.
We're not setting up a ten year process to
get to market.
Six years ago he co-founded Labdoor
with the goal of bringing more transparency
to the supplements industry.
The company has received funding from several
prominent angel investors and venture capitalists
including Mark Cuban and Y Combinator.
Are there any results that have really surprised
you
either in terms of 'wow this has exactly what
it says and is pretty effective'
or falling way short of what it's promise
is?
Yeah so there's certain categories, if you
look at like a vitamin D or magnesium
or kind of these simple ingredients, like
creatine,
you'll find that the vast majority of products
will be very good, you know,
so it might be 70, 80, 90% of the market is
clean.
And then there's other categories like Garcinia
Cambogia
is something that Doctor Oz had been really
pushing heavily
and when we tested in 2017 we found that 70%
of the products didn't have the active ingredients
up to the label.
The company buys the products right off the
shelves
and then posts the test results for free on its website.
It makes money when people click through to
purchase an item.
People might think that there's a conflict
of interest there
if you are testing these products but also
in a way marketing them.
How do you justify that?
Well often find is that it's not the most
popular product that wins categories
it's not the thing that the big brand names
that you might have heard of
often is like a B or a C grade on our site.
The real top A grade products tend to be something
that people haven't ever heard of before.
So it's the protein powder from England, it's
the fish oil from Belgium.
These companies in some cases have never even
sold in the US
and once we find them, we start testing, they
actually find a market in the US
to actually start selling.
Fish oil doesn't sound that far from snake
oil.
What did you go in thinking about supplements
and have you changed the way you thought about
dietary supplements?
I think I probably went through three phases
of my life
so like when I was in high school and I was
playing sports
it was like I would take the protein powders
and the creatines and whatever
I just wanted to, I would buy whatever was
the most popular right
or whatever like my friend recommended, right,
and that's the classic thing that people start with.
and then, you know, I went to college and
I started researching the science behind it
and I was just hit me and I kind of went the
other way and I was like I don't want to take anything
because I, like I don't know what's in these
products, right?
And then once we started testing these products,
you can definitely find, like
we found protein powders that say they had,
they claimed 25 grams of protein per scoop
and they had 5 or 10 grams.
And someone took the worst product every single
day, they would actually absolutely get sick, right?
And if they took the worst fish oil that had
10% or less Omega 3s
it wouldn't be that effective, right?
And so this idea of we can find out what's
safe and effective just by testing the products
and if we can do that then if you only took
the best products
then you would actually see an effect.
And so I think the supplement has a lot of
great players and a lot of bad players, right?
And our job is to kind of be the referee and
kind of separate the two.
Labdoor once tested male libido supplements
marketed by Infowars founder Alex Jones.
Though taking them is unlikely to increase
libido,
they probably also won't do much harm the
company found.
Both sides got what they wanted out of that
story, like
Alex Jones was really excited that it was
all pure
and I think the other side of the media was
very, kind of frustrated by the, kind of,
the extreme claims that were being made
about what might actually happen with your health.
For us, like, we do the testing, we tell you
what actually happened
and then you can read that very different
ways.
Thanedar plans to create a decentralized network
of laboratories called TEST.
Consumers would no longer have to trust a
single third party, including Labdoor or the FDA.
Instead, through a decentralized database
known as a blockchain
participants, including the supplement manufacturers
themselves
could actually place bets using tokens issued
by TEST as to whether a product would pass muster.
In a classic certification, someone, like
the company would pay for a certification
and we would, like anyone would deliver it.
And I think that, that centralization can
cause kind of some bias
when you're directly paying the people who
give you a rating
with like a credit rating agency, you have
a lot of risk.
We want to use this token as that curation
mechanism for this registry
so that we can basically have an open, decentralized
way
for one, any lab can come in and if they're
registered, if they pass the testing,
they can actually, they can contribute,
they can actually make money as a testing lab for this registry.
And so it doesn't just have to be us, anyone
can do testing.
And so I think it becomes a self selection
mechanism
where the best companies, the best products
will actually rise to the top
by just the factor of this kind of curation
this prediction system
and the idea of, kind of, the best companies
kind of self select into the market.
And Thanedar says his vision of a market solution
to consumer safety concerns
isn't limited to supplements.
Labdoor has it's sights set on another giant
market: marijuana.
It's a market that has basically come out
of nowhere
and there's a lot of testing to be done, there's
a lot of inconsistencies.
Here in California, now with recreational
legalization
there's actually mandatory testing and there's
a whole system of labs
so how does your vision fit into that?
I think the biggest thing for that is convincing
people to test publicly.
Don't, like there's a hundred things on the
shelf
you don't want to know the 10 things that
fail, you want to know the number one best thing, right?
Like, if there was like a spotlight that like,
was like this was the number one best product
and you could just take it off and walk out
the store that would be magical, right?
And the kind of experience we're trying to
make
is like take those hundred products and like
put the spotlight on the one best product.
And that's, more than just saying hey it passed
government,
like the minimum government regulations,
it's like the best product just buy this and
you'll be happy.
And that's the thing that we're really trying
to get to.